[Música]
el ejército de ucrania ocupa el puesto
número 22 de los ejércitos más poderosos
del mundo según el global fair power una
consultora de defensa que elabora su
índice de acuerdo a numerosas variables
que incluyen el poderío militar la
economía la capacidad logística o
también la geografía la diferencia entre
los presupuestos anuales de los dos
países en el conflicto en esta guerra
que estamos viendo destinan a la defensa
da una idea de la magnitud y las
diferencias en su poderío militar rusia
por ejemplo gasta 154 mil millones de
dólares al año mientras que ucrania
invierte unos 11 mil millones
la estrategia táctica y el despliegue de
rusia han sido analizados en profundidad
desde un comienzo de animación en
ucrania pero se hablaba relativamente
muy poco de la estrategia de ucrania las
fuerzas en el terreno que lucha para
evitar que los rusos rodeen la capital
kiev pero realmente se sabe muy poco
sobre lo que están haciendo o también de
qué manera para ello entonces sí para
saber qué es lo que están haciendo los
ucranianos vamos a saludar a alejandro
corbacho él es experto en temas
militares y nucleares además director el
observatorio de seguridad y defensa de
la universidad semana argentina gracias
por estar con nosotros en directo
américa de francés de 4 alejandro y por
supuesto le quiero preguntar lo primero
cuál es la capacidad real del ejército
de ucrania sobre todo en esa guerra
muy bien buenos días bueno quería
decirles la capacidad si usted la ve al
inicio del conflicto era bueno victoria
aplastante por parte de rusia dado la
diferencia numérica lo que se estaba
mostrando ahora lo que estamos viendo ya
casi dos meses de las operaciones es que
el ejército ucraniano se fue preparando
a partir especialmente a partir del 2014
para enfrentar un ataque ruso y entonces
lo que estamos viendo nosotros en
realidad por primera vez en la historia
moderna y en europa una guerra híbrida y
ofensiva o sea
inicialmente la guerra era ofensiva
defensiva no dios por un lado e impide
implica el empleo de armamento por otro
lado también implica el empleo de otro
tipo de recursos como es la información
el ciberespacio para poder combatir
entonces la preparación lo que estamos
viendo hasta ahora es que la preparación
del ejército ucraniano ha sido esta muy
buena porque no enfrenta
masa de fuerza frente a otra masa de
fuerza que era lo que sería lo
tradicional en el combate tradicional no
lo esperable y sin embargo está logrando
este gracias justamente a contar con
armamento muy sofisticado muy muy
preparado que yo creo que los los rusos
no estaban no esperaban encontrarse con
eso lograr hacer operaciones de ataque y
replegarse e infligirles daños que le
impiden el libre movimiento de las
tropas rusas en el territorio claro de
jandro y precisamente eso le quería
preguntar cuánto ha enriquecido la arte
y ucraniana las oraciones de los países
occidentales
muy gran enorme cantidad de los números
se habla de 800 millones 1800 millones o
sea pero en realidad lo que están
obteniendo es armamento de gran
capacidad sofisticado moderno actual y
además saber utilizar lo que esto es muy
importante también no uno de los uno de
los problemas de usted les puede dar a
cualquier país un armamento pero si
quienes lo manejan no lo saben operar
están en muy mala situación
están recibiendo sobre todo misiles
antiaéreos misiles antitanques en drones
que realmente han mostrado una capacidad
muy bien empleados han mostrado una gran
capacidad de destrucción o por lo menos
frenan desde disputan y ensucian las
operaciones como la plantean en los los
rusos que ya esto está acompañado por
supuesto una cantidad de información
satelital que
esta disposición del alto mando
ucraniano quien mantiene las capacidades
comando y control por lo cual esto
quiere decir que tienen aparatos que les
permiten mantener contacto a pesar de no
estar a la vista o digamos a través del
medio del ciberespacio no
conflicto si alejandro es evidente que
como estábamos conversando aquí en esa
entrevista las armas que le ha dado
occidente a ucrania pero también usted
hablaba un punto muy importante y es que
evidentemente estas armas no tienen
ninguna validez y el ejército ruso y el
ejército ucraniano perdón y los
ucranianos en el terreno defendiendo su
país y su territorio no lo pueden
utilizar digamos que cuánto tiempo a lo
mejor ellos se estuvieron preparando
para para esta guerra antes de esta
guerra miembros de las milicias
occidentales o de eeuu se puede decir
que estaban en territorio ucraniano
capacitando a todas estas personas
bueno no se puede puede ser desde
algunos países de la otan el tema es que
los oficiales oficiales ucranianos han
tomado cursos en gran cantidad si se
habla de 72 mil
hombres de ucrania participaron en un
entrenamiento militar de en países de la
otan o en los eeuu sobre todo a partir
del 2014 a carl el tema es que rusia
vino llevando adelante una serie de
acciones de
ocupación territorial exitosas antes de
digamos con ucrania y perdón con un
crimen que vamos a parar hasta crimea
muy muy exitosas crimea lo mismo
entonces ahí sí ya este se comenzaron
fuertemente a preparar cómo enfrentar a
los rusos y ahí los rusos mostraron
cuáles serían cuáles serían sus métodos
entonces se han se han preparado para
eso y bueno y en este momento hay
campamentos que no podemos decir dónde
están no es posible ubicar donde se
sigue entrenando al personal y además es
personal que no hay gente que es que
tiene el nivel de educación porque esto
es muy importante no solamente manejar
un fusil de asalto yo pensando en otras
guerras en otros territorios sino que es
manejar equipo más sofisticado y
teniendo una población con un nivel
educativo mejor por supuesto que es
mucho más más fácil que lo incorpore
además algo que usted mencionó está
realmente la voluntad de defender el
territorio hasta las últimas
consecuencias esto está enraizado en la
historia de la región no claro que
precisamente hoy también lo ratificó el
gobierno de ucrania defender su
territorio cueste lo que cueste hasta
las últimas consecuencias pero alejandro
hablemos específicamente de este
armamento que le ha sido digamos
abandonado regalado ucrania hablemos de
los misiles tipo jabalina en la o el
tipo de momento catalogado como el
antitanque más moderno y poderoso del
mundo cuál ha sido la eficacia
importancia en esta resistencia contra
el ejército ruso
bueno la importancia es que
han impedido desarticulado ataques el
blindado es un elemento el vehículo
blindado los tanques son elementos con
los cuales sirven para avanzar
protegiendo a la infantería si usted
digamos tiene un arma antitanque muy
efectiva que no es otro tanque sino que
es un arma portátil móvil desde
distintos puntos puede atacar a estos
blindados y paralizar las acciones
militares las operaciones en los que
estábamos viendo también es que los
rusos parecen parecería que tienen
problemas de identificar a los
atacantes porque usted ya ha visto
muchos videos y muchas si tienes uno
tendería a creer que
es muy fácil identificar a través de
visores infrarrojos del ataque en el
ataque de personal enemigo sin embargo
esto no parece ser tan tan tan así no
está ocurriendo entonces en lo que lo
que ocurre es que de día digamos podrán
los y tener alguna visión y control del
espacio pero de noche tienen progresos
porque son atacados por equipos o grupos
que atacan y se pueden desplegar
rápidamente
y un modelo de defensa flexible claro
alejandro también sin embargo hemos
visto muchos ataques del ejército ruso
vía aérea hacia los depósitos de armas
de los ucranianos y absolutamente todo
lo que tiene que ver con su capacidad
militar para una respuesta a estos
ataques rusos que tan diezmada se ha
visto la capacidad en medio de estos
constantes constantes bombardeos a estas
instalaciones de las que hablaba al
principio
bueno en principio pueden produjeron
algún daño un daño importante pero se
sigue esto es como una como si usted
conoce un camino de hormigas destruye
seguro si aparecen otros y en gran
cantidad entonces en la medida que rusia
identifica centros de concentración de
armamento es donde va a atacar y eso lo
que usted le ve en las noticias cuando
rusia ataca hacia el este digamos sea se
aproxima a la perdón hacia el oeste así
cuando se aproxima a la frontera de la
de la otan pero suso en ataques como
usted bien dijo de la de la aviación
tratando de impedir esto no han sido del
todo exitoso porque sigue existiendo
sigue habiendo resistencia y la capital
por ejemplo ha ofrecido una resistencia
extraordinaria a qué se debe el éxito de
la resistencia de las fuerzas ucranianas
y también los civiles que se han
aplicado las calles a luchar por su país
el éxito se debe a que hubo una gran
preparación a que ofrecen un tipo un
modelo de resistencia
que no en la cual no son masacrados o
aniquilados todos en un combate una
batalla decisiva sino que están esté
logrando
justamente éstos hacer estos ataques que
frenan o impiden el avance de las
fuerzas le generan muchas bajas esto se
está transformando en una guerra de
desgaste es una guerra de desgaste y
sobre todo ayudado por inicialmente la
confianza o la sobre confianza rusa de
que era una operación justamente
especial lo cual era algo repetir una
suerte de paseo de
por el campo no no nos van a encontrar
gran resistencia con lo cual esto
requiere que a los rusos lo que esto le
implica es nueva logística nueva
disposición de tropas y el empleo de
otro modo o el empleo de unidad de armas
que hasta el momento no estarían no
estaban dispuestos a utilizar